bei mir im studio jetzt direkt von den
demonstrationen unser chefredakteur
julian reichelt
wir hatten vorhin schon einmal kurz
gesprochen als du dort warst was sind
jetzt seine empfindungen dort was wir
menschen waren vor allem jetzt auf der
straße die stundenlang
trotz der auflösung der demonstration
nicht gewichen sind das was man da sieht
ist beunruhigend dass kann man so ganz
klar sagen was das für menschen sind ich
glaube das kann man nicht so klar sagen
dafür ist das bild viel zu diffus dass
es auf jeden fall gibt es ein
rechtsextremer und rechtsradikale die
treten da auch sehr massiv und sehr
martialisch auf es gibt interessante
weise darüber haben in den letzten
wochen monaten hier ja auch häufiger
geredet ein sehr esoterisch angehauchte
das publikum also der heilpraktiker
physiotherapeuten die ja auch teilweise
sehr esoterisch anmutenden ideen äußern
ich habe aber auch versucht durch die
polizei linien weg das war nicht immer
ganz leicht die polizei versucht die
demonstranten zurückzudrängen das immer
noch dabei relativ moderat übrigens muss
ich sagen er versucht mit diesen
demonstranten irgendwie ins gespräch zu
kommen
gerade menschen ja der da sehen wir zum
beispiel mich im gespräch mit einer
jungen dame die mir erzählt hat sie sei
in der veranstaltungsbranche tätig kommt
aus berlin
seine veranstaltungsbranche tätig habe
früher
wir haben zum beispiel beim dfb pokal
bei der fashion week er gemacht und sei
jetzt ohne arbeit ohne perspektive und
ohne das leben was sie bis vor kurzem
gelebt hat und das war ein kurzes
gespräch eine momentaufnahme man hat
hier schon ein gefühl dafür aus welchem
milieu jemand kommt was die politischen
ansichten so in etwa sein mögen und da
würde ich mal sagen das war mitte mitte
zumindest so wie ich das erlebt habe die
man sich vorstellen kann aber trotzdem
total aufgebracht
gegenüber der politik der regierung
besonders gegen wurde im gesetz was da
heute beschlossen und besprochen wurde
das ist das glaube ich was einem sorgen
machen muss ja es gibt immer die ränder
der gesellschaft die sich oder des
politischen spektrums die sich bei
solchen veranstaltungen treffen
aber dazwischen ist inzwischen habe ich
das gefühl mehr als noch vor einigen
wochen und einigen monaten das sind
menschen die man jetzt erst mal als in
einfach
vernünftig verorten würde die sich aber
besonders durch die ständige information
in dieser blase social media inzwischen
enorm radikalisiert haben und natürlich
auch durch die wirtschaftlichen sorgen
die sie haben also dass diese menschen
wegen des gesetzes heute auf die straße
oder ist das heute nur der anlass für
die demonstration gewesen also regen
sich wirklich so sehr über dieses eine
gesetz auf oder hat sich da ganz viel
angestaut ich habe auch mehrere menschen
gefragt die ich jetzt wie gesagt das
kann man immer nicht so ganz klar
zuordnen aber die ich jetzt als nicht
radikal in der wolle gefärbter sozusagen
empfinden würde warum sie ausgerechnet
an diesem ort zu diesem zeitpunkt und
mit diesen in diesem umfeld sich bewegen
und die einhellige antwort war ja wo
sollen wir denn sonst hin geben ja also
das ist schon ein beunruhigender trend
glaube ich den mann da sieht dass
menschen sich dorthin getrieben fühlen
ob sie dorthin getrieben sind es etwas
anderes aber sie fühlen sich dorthin
getrieben weil sie das gefühl haben und
in der wahrnehmung leben dass ihr
protest ihr widerspruch nicht
ausreichend gehör findet und tatsächlich
auch dass sie sozusagen durch neue
gesetze mundtot gemacht werden
wir haben das von unseren kollegen die
sich dann noch auf der straße befinden
schon gehört dass es da auch ganz ganz
crew der ansichten gibt ja ich glaube
auch nicht dass irgend jemand mundtot
gemacht werden soll aber diese
wahrnehmung hat ihren weg das muss man
ganz klar sagen in ein publikum eher in
der mitte unserer gesellschaft gefunden
und sie stehen da jetzt gerade vom
wasserwerfer jetzt sprechen wir viel
über die demonstration auslöser
zumindest heute ist das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz das im bundestag
heute debattiert wurde die abstimmung
jetzt gerade läuft um das gesetz herum
gibt es auch hier kritik aus den
demokratischen reihen des parlaments wir
haben gerade christian lindner unter
anderem dazu gehört was sind die
wichtigsten kritikpunkte an diesem
gesetz und vor allem was ändert sich
wenn es jetzt tatsächlich dann
durchkommt ich glaube nicht dass ich
jetzt tatsächlich etwas ändert aber
grundsätzlich ist ein gesetz ja immer
erst mal einfallstor für die
möglichkeiten die es theoretisch
geschafft und die befugnisse die es für
jens spahn
dass gesundheitsminister schafft die
sind durchaus gegeben
und da gibt es sozusagen
durchgriffsrechte die über seine
bisherigen rechte hinausgehen die aber
weit entfernt sind von dem was dort auf
der straße teilweise behauptet wird dass
corona ermächtigungsgesetz in anlehnung
an das reiche mächtige setzt mit dem
adolf hitler quasi seine macht gesichert
hat das ist natürlich in keiner weise
vergleichbar aber es ist ja trotzdem
ganz wichtiger entscheidender und
interessanter punkt als diese ganze
corona pandemie losging und die ersten
gesetze verabschiedet worden ging es
immer wieder um dieses wort ermächtigung
ja wir haben damals gesagt das ist
vielleicht keine besonders kluge
wortwahl vor dem hintergrund der
deutschen geschichte und damals dieses
jahr was für soll das denn heißen soll
dass jetzt etwa nazi-vergleiche sein
nein wir haben damals schon gesagt es
ermöglicht halt genau diese
argumentation wenn ich es ermächtigungen
werden in den texten teilweise
ermächtigungen das wort drinsteht oder
so gesprochen wird naja dann mache ich
es den leuten halt auch deutlich
leichter ermächtigungen zu sagen und ich
glaube im nachhinein dass man natürlich
immer schlauer aber das war schon damals
erkennbar dass das kein besonders guter
weg ist und so funktionieren ja diese
verschwörung mythen auf social media und
allen gruppen dass man sich so kleine
nagels wo man auch wenn man es gab doch
jetzt habe ich es gefunden da ist ja die
wahrheit glänzt sie vor sich hin
sozusagen sich dir aussucht und darum
eine ganze geschichte spinnt das ist
genau das was dort gerade passiert und
wofür das sieht man auf dieser
demonstration habe ich es da zumindest
erlebt ganz deutlich wo vier wofür auch
menschen anfällig sind die entweder
vorher ja unpolitisch waren die eher dem
linken spektrum links liberal mit links
spektrum zuzurechnen weil das ist ein
vollkommen diffus unübersichtliches bild
geworden jetzt erreicht uns gerade die
nachricht dass dieses neue
infektionsschutzgesetz vom bundestag
beschlossen worden ist die abstimmung
jetzt also durch aber julian noch einmal
auf die generelle corona politik zu
sprechen zu kommen
das bedeutet natürlich jetzt
einige sachen die vereinfacht werden für
angela merkel und die
ministerpräsidenten nächste woche
treffen sie sich wieder für die nächste
ministerpräsident konferenz von genau
dort kommen ja jetzt eigentlich die
ganze zeit schon über die maßnahmen die
über unseren alltag etwas mitbestimmen
wie es sein blick darauf was da vor
allem in den letzten tagen passiert ist
am montag sehr viel streit und dann am
ende ein appell jetzt nächste woche
gleich die nächste ministerpräsident
konferenz was bedeutet dass politischen
vor allem was bedeutet auch für die
menschen draußen was für ein gefühl
haben sie wenn es jetzt so ein streit
gibt und man sich auf nichts merkt ja
das ist er ganz schwer glaube ich zu
sagen was die menschen für ein gefühl
haben wie gesagt auch da ist das bild
gerade diffus ich glaube was man wenn
man sich die letzten monate anschaut
durchaus sagen kann ist das ist dieses
durchregieren die regierung entscheidet
und greift brutalst auf mich ein und
durch das ist ja nicht das was passiert
ist
er ist ein teilweise sehr harte und
harsche maßnahmen verabschiedet worden
aber der durchgriff des staates das ist
ja auch so ein bisschen die angst und
sorge leute die da gerade demonstrieren
dass der mit eiserner hand dann nach
hause kommt und guckt wer sitzt da bei
mir zu hause das ist ja nicht der fall
wir haben deswegen glaube ich auch
dieses gesetz schafft tendenziell eher
eine grundlage
manche beschlüsse einheitlicher
durchsetzen zu können ist es aus meiner
sicht ich glaube auch nicht dass man da
diese sorge haben muss die grundlage für
den staat eisern mit eiserner faust
durchzugreifen
aber was wir in den letzten tagen
gesehen haben
besonders bei diesem thema ein freund
regel und treffen sie sich nur mit einem
haushalt ja das sind natürlich regeln
die erstens vollkommen unpraktikabel
sind die vollkommen weltfremd sind
vollkommen realitätsfremd jeder mensch
der kinder hat würde sofort sagen was
auf ihr könnt den kindern nicht sagen
ihr dürft nur noch die nächsten wochen
einen freund treffen
das ist vorbei an jeglicher
lebensrealität von normalen menschen das
sehen ja selbst unter den
ministerpräsidenten
einige sodass sehen in der opposition so
viele so ich weiß dass das auch von den
leuten die es mit entschieden haben auch
sehr viele so sehen und da muss man
immer sagen wenn ich dinge entscheide
die an der lebensrealität vollkommen
vorbei gehen und menschen angst machen
menschen haben angst davor dass sie auf
einmal nur noch ein
was halten oder ihrem kind sagen müssen
du darfst die johanna treffen sondern
nur noch die eva das macht menschen
angst und wenn ich menschen angst machen
dann muss ich mich auch nicht wundern
wenn sie feucht voll überreagieren und
ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen die
dynamik die man da gerade sieht und ich
glaube es ist meine persönliche meinung
da wäre unsere regierung gut beraten
maßnahmen zu treffen die der
lebensrealität der menschen in diesem
land entsprechen und nicht so einen
quatsch wie mit der ein freund regelt
dass jedes kind sich aussuchen muss wen
es trifft und wen sie nächsten wochen
nicht mehr trifft mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren